joining us on the line is john bolton he
served as national security advisor to
president trump from april 9 2018 to
september 10th
2019 and as u.s ambassador to the u.n
from 2005
to 2006 his new book is the room where
it happened to white house
memoir ambassador bolton national
security adviser bolton thanks so much
for joining the show really appreciate
it well thank you very much for having
me glad to be here
so why don't we talk a little bit
obviously about the sort of hot
controversy that has surrounded
your book so there's a lot in the book
about president trump personally
and about his handling of foreign policy
so why don't we begin
with i think some of the stuff in the
book that actually talks about some of
the good stuff that president trump did
so while you were there
there were some good things that
happened i mean the president was for
example
very harsh on iran in certain ways
although you're critical of his
treatment in other ways
in some ways he was harsh on china in
some ways he was not harsh on china why
don't you give us sort of the fully
rounded picture from inside the room
as to the president's perspective and
the administration's perspective on
those two
geopolitical opponents of the united
states well what i tried to do
across the board was was uh say
what happened in some of these very
complex issues and i thought it was
important
uh to show the places not simply where i
disagreed with
trump decisions but where i agreed with
them because i think one of the
unfortunate aspects about the trump
presidency is that all of american
politics has been torqued around
him people who who support him
support him 100 percent and people who
oppose him oppose him a hundred percent
and i didn't get into politics because
of
support for any individual even even
barry goldwater the first
uh person i campaigned for i got into
politics because of philosophy
and that's what i felt really should be
the mainstay of this so look on iran
uh i thought trump was 100 correct in
what he said in the 2016 campaign that
we needed to get out of the iran
nuclear deal that obama had negotiated i
thought it
not only didn't solve the problem of
iran's nuclear weapons program it made
it worse
uh so we did get out and imposed strict
sanctions and it had a
dramatic impact on iran's capabilities
and yet at the same time uh trump was
was always eager for an opportunity to
sit down with the ayatollahs and
negotiate another deal
i didn't think that would work because i
don't think the
regime in tehran has ever made a
strategic decision to give up nuclear
weapons and that pursuing negotiations
was a big mistake now these days
somebody and none of us know who for
sure
is systematically exploding facilities
in iran's nuclear weapons and ballistic
missile programs
and if they continue at their present
rate that may do that may go a long way
to solving the problem
on china to be clear i think china is
the existential threat to the united
states in the 21st century and to many
of our allies
i think trump uh perceived correctly
that china's economic power was the was
the
basis on which political and economic
political and military power could be
projected
and that it was a mistake uh that prior
administrations had committed to allow
china to abuse the international
economic system
so the attack on
uh the the trade war with china uh
which in trump's mind came from the
trade deficit but which was
caused by what we call the structural
issues china's
systematic theft of intellectual
property from the u.s and europe and
japan for decades
it's forced technology transfers
discrimination against
foreign businesses and investors uh was
all necessary to get
china's attention to say we're not going
to accept it anymore we're not going to
accept your use of the world trade
organization
for mercantilist purposes and we
understand if we don't stop you on the
economic policies
uh that that these will be translated
into consequences uh
in the east china sea the south china
sea cyberspace
outer space and elsewhere now again all
that said i i
worry in a second term that trump will
still be pursuing
the administration's great white whale
which is the big china trade deal
and that many of the tough positions
that are being taken now will be
reversed
so ambassador bolton let's talk for a
second about that because it seems like
a lot of the policies as implemented
actually kind of went the way that you
wanted them to go meaning that that
president trump has been
as you say in terms of policy fairly
hawkish on china
on iran obviously pulled out of the iran
nuclear deal it seems that he has a
personal tendency that
is pretty obvious to third-party
observers to try and reach out
personally to people he he believes
almost like fdr did in a sort of bizarre
personal diplomacy where if he is
friendly with somebody
then magically this will change the
nature of the deal that is to be struck
fdr famously thought this about stalin
and ended up being played by stalin
trump obviously thinks this about kim
jong-un for example and that hasn't
worked out to anybody's
benefit how much of that do you think is
is actually going to be effectuated in
policy and how much of that is just the
fact that
you know trump mouths off and he says
things that he thinks are going to win
him admirers and in particular circles
so for example in the book
you talk about his relationship with xi
jinping and some of the things that he
has said to the chinese government
about human rights violations and sort
of shying off of them how much of that
do you think is seriously reflected in
policy and how much of that is just
trump you know trying to warm people up
in a sort of bizarre and awkward way
well i think the test the the answer to
your question is
is in the test of what uh trump actually
believes and and this to me is the most
uh troubling uh aspect of his presidency
which is that at bottom there is no
trump philosophy
uh he's not a conservative republican
now i don't mean to say by that he's a
liberal democrat because he's certainly
not he's not
anything and the the phenomenon
that i saw over and over again was that
critically important
decisions in national security policy
were often made not on the basis of the
merits of the arguments
for or against a particular policy but
ultimately because of what trump feared
the domestic political blowback would be
if he did
the wrong thing uh i think in the case
of
uh china it's he he understood fully
that
that many people uh believe that uh
that china's actions against the united
states are part of a systematic effort
to replace us
uh in our position in the international
system and and he knew that if he looked
like he was
too accommodating to china uh that he
would be criticized for it he knew
ultimately on afghanistan for example
that if he invited the taliban to camp
david that there'd be
a volcanic reaction against that but
but what happens in a second trump turn
if you don't have a fundamental
philosophy to ground yourself in
and you're reacting to political
pressure
once you're re-elected you never have to
face the voters again that's why i worry
that a second trump term
would turn out in ways that many
conservatives would be amazed surprised
and
and disappointed in so there's still
some people in the administration who
tend to
kind of mirror some of your beliefs
certainly on foreign policy secretary of
state mike pompeo i know that you
had some conflicts while you're at the
administration obviously but secretary
of state pompeo is pretty hawkish on
china he's pretty hawkish on iran he's
hawkish in the middle east
uh i know that obviously jared kushner
when it comes to middle eastern policy
is extraordinarily pro-israel
um the the the advisers who remain uh
do do they seem as though they're going
to be giving him advice that leads him
toward a more conciliatory position
toward opponents of the united states or
do you think that he's still
it seems like a lot of trump's decision
making in other words is in fact shaped
by advisers who are whispering in his
ears and it seems like a lot of the
people who are whispering into his
ears not people outside government
necessarily people who are inside the
government
are still people who are generally you
know hawkish on foreign policy
well certainly some of them are there's
there's no doubt about it i i'd add mark
esper the secretary of defense
i think i've known him for many years
he's a solid conservative vice president
uh but there are plenty that uh yeah
mike pence for sure who has done a lot
of his best work and i say this in the
book behind the scenes in ways that
probably no one will ever
fully appreciate but there are plenty of
other people inside the administration
who argue exactly the contrary steve
mnuchin for example
uh who is known to republicans on the
hill as shanghai steve
uh is uh is is very lenient in his
attitude toward china
uh and i would not underestimate the
impact of people
outside the administration some members
of congress
others that the president talks to who
don't
understand the slightest thing about
some of these issues but nonetheless
have strong opinions on them
so i come back to ultimately the buck
does stop
on the resolute desk in the oval office
and that's why you have to ask yourself
what's the president's basic philosophy
and he doesn't have one if he doesn't
have one
that's a problem so ambassador bolton
you famously suggested
as as the book rolled out that you won't
be voting for president trump in in 2020
and that you might vote third party um
so
let's talk about joe biden because that
is the choice for many americans is not
to vote third party it's do you vote for
trump to stop joe biden or do you vote
for joe biden to stop trump
what do you make of joe biden because as
much as you disagree with president
trump's lack of sort of centralizing
philosophy joe biden has been wrong on
every foreign policy issue of the last
four decades essentially
uh sure that's that's correct and i look
i've known him for a long time not only
in his uh
capacity on the senate foreign relations
committee but on the senate judiciary
committee when he
chaired the hearings that sank the
nomination of my former law professor
bob bork
in one of the most unfair displays of
senatorial action in american history uh
this is a very unhappy election for me
uh uh neither neither one of these uh
candidates really reflects the
philosophy i think will be
uh reagan-esque and and provide for an
america that
that prevails uh and in a peaceful way
through a strong position
uh so that's well that's one reason i'm
not gonna vote for bud and i agree with
you completely because
his at best his uh policies will be
another four years of the obama
administration
i'm not actually going to vote for a
third party because i don't think there
are any that
that i'm going to write in somebody
whose name is yet to be determined
because
because i don't see either of the
candidates uh
being being ones that i can support in
good conscience
are you afraid that if joe biden were to
be elected president that it would that
he'd end up rolling back some of the
policies he yourself
were instrumental in promoting and and
here i speak not just about the movement
of the embassy to jerusalem
in israel but the reinculcation of an
iran deal the pursuit of a softer
position on china
well i think it's certainly a risk and
it's one reason why
my advice to to conservatives
across the board is that it's uh
absolutely critical that we preserve the
senate majority that republicans now
hold if we lose that
uh i i think this would be uh this would
be
catastrophic for the united states some
of the things that trump has done
as happens in any administration i do
not think are reversible i don't i don't
think joe biden is going to pull the
embassy out of jerusalem
but i do think it's possible whether he
actually
re-enters the iran nuclear deal or just
tries to negotiate another deal
that uh that he will be doing things as
i said a moment ago
that are more characteristic of the
obama administration than anything in
the trump administration i'm not going
to be happy
on the morning of november the 4th
whichever one of them wins
ambassador john bolton his book is the
room where it happened a white house
memoir it's definitely an informative
look
inside how policy how the sausage was
made inside the white house ambassador
bolton honest man i appreciate your time
sir
well thank you very much for having me i
appreciate it
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content